audio recognition facial recognition
software automated cars robotic
surgeries personalized product
recommendations as you browse through a
website smart cities and much more all
these miracles are a result of machine
learning and artificial intelligence
this vitally important field a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence is attracting a lot of
attention lately
both for its technological breakthroughs
and lucrative career opportunities
employment website indeed.com has listed
machine learning engineers as number one
amongst the best jobs in the us
citing a 344 rate of growth and a
minimum salary of 140 dollars per annum
overall computer and information
technology jobs are booming with
employment projected to grow 11 percent
from 2019 to 2029.
more specifically the future of jobs
report 2020 predicts that artificial
intelligence will create 12 million new
jobs across 26 countries by 2025
representing a net gain of 97 million
new jobs created while 85 million are
displaced
with high demand for ai and machine
learning talent driving high salaries
the majority of machine learning jobs
pay well over 100 000 to 200 000
per annum
so how do you become a well-paid machine
learning engineer or tap into other
machine learning related career
opportunities if you're one of the
aspiring machine learning engineers then
it's a perfect time that you start
taking your career options seriously
simply learn skill up program is
dedicated to help you with the
best-in-class training from the
real-time industry experts with hands-on
projects to put your skills to rigorous
tests and get you industry ready the
best part is all of this is for free of
cost yes you can start your machine
learning journey for free of cost
the course is 10 hours long and all the
modules in it are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace anytime anywhere after completing
this course you are awarded a course
completion certificate by skillup the
course comprises cutting-edge
technicalities in machine learning
throughout the course you will have an
in-depth understanding of machine
learning fundamentals time series
analysis in r and much more and
advancing ahead you will be introduced
to some of the significant machine
learning concepts like linear regression
decision tree in our support vector
machine in our hierarchical clustering
in our our programming basics logical
regression random forest in r and much
more throughout the course you will be
having a detailed theoretical
explanation from the industry experts
and hands-on learning experience with
machine learning with r
so now you might be thinking who is
eligible to take up this course right
well there are no prerequisites to
enroll into this course each of you who
has a sale for mastering artificial
intelligence and machine learning can
take up this course irrespective of your
experience
experienced industry experts have
specifically designed this
well-structured beginners course to
enable a smooth learning journey
skillups introductory course is also
recommended for those who have some
fundamental knowledge of programming but
are looking to upgrade themselves with
critical ai and ml concepts this course
also caters both beginners and
professionals in machine learning
development data science data analytics
and much more this self-paced course
helps you master machine learning fund
members so what are you waiting for head
straight to our scale-up page and enrich
your machine learning knowledge by
enrolling in our free introduction to
machine learning with our course this
will get you closer to your dreams and
what can be better than a free
certificate to strengthen your profile
trust me certifications bring you one
step closer to bagging the opportunity
and becoming a machine learning expert
today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified click here